la routine d'amendé richard a bien
changé depuis deux semaines son gilet
jaune viennent en évidence son tableau
bord de sa voiture est devenue un mode
de vie pour elle comme pour des millions
de français qui ont du mal à boucler
leur budget la hausse des taxes sur le
carburant a été une goutte de trop vous
qui travaille on travaille plus pour
gagner moins c'est clair non pas
possible et avec toutes les taxes
clients en plus c'est c'est juste un
vivat poids ça devient vraiment
invivable pour cette mère de famille
seront sur ce rond point à quinze
minutes de chez elle pour manifester son
mécontentement
un rond-point transformée en campement
où se relaient nuit et toujours les
gilets jaunes de la région ici pas
question de bloquer la circulation ou
dans l'été des automobilistes les gilets
jaunes demande simplement le conducteur
de manifester leur appui à coups de
klaxon la solidarité se manifeste aussi
par les dons en nourriture eau qu une
aide bienvenue quand pour tous les amis
qu'il s'est fait ici c'est le désespoir
qui a fait descendre amandine dans la
rue on explique quoi nos enfants quand
on peut falloir acheter de nouveaux amis
on explique one aux enfants quand maman
ils n'osent pas à table tu manges pas
non j'ai pas fin à tapas fin tu avais
déjà patent ce midi on explique sakho
non à nos enfants en fait tous ici ont
suivi avec attention les récentes
concessions annoncées par le
gouvernement
l'annulation des hausses de taxes sur le
carburant le gel des tarifs du gaz et de
l'électricité
la hausse du salaire minimum trop peu
trop tard à leurs yeux
non non c'était il ya trois semaines
qu'il fallait nous jeter un bon pain là
il nous jette des miettes on n'en veut
pas de lorgnette là à la base c'était la
hausse des taxes
maintenant on fait carrément cemac ronde
émission ton gouvernement on n'en veut
plus un président mac rang qu'ils jugent
froid distant et arrogant samedi dernier
les gilets jaunes du rond-point de
senlis s'étaient rendus manifester à
paris une rose jaune à la main notre
message c'est de dire qu'on était venu
nombreux mais qu'on était venus en paix
face aux forces de l'ordre
amandine comme les autres gilet jaune de
senlis rejette toute violence
mais ce qu'elle déplore surtout c'est
qu'elle semble être le seul moyen de se
faire entendre du gouvernement alors que
le soleil se couche ici ces gilets
jaunes s'apprêtent à passer leur 13ème
nuits d'affilée sur ce rond-point
toujours motivé toujours déterminée
certains parlent même déjà d'y passer
noël et jour de l'an
un verre de café à la main pour se
donner du courage pour se réchauffer ils
font des plans pour la manifestation de
samedi à paris consciente des risques
amandine pense surtout à ses deux fils
qu'elle fois moins souvent ces jours ci
mais qui occupe toutes ses pensées
je pense que c'est même certain que tous
les gens qui sont là et qui ont des
enfants font ça pour leurs enfants alors
que les gilets jaunes s'apprêtent à
marcher sur paris pour quatrième samedi
le mouvement inquiète de plus en plus au
pays
mais huit français sur dix selon un
sondage paru aujourd'hui les trouve
toujours populaire solidaires et
courageux